hello everyone and welcome back to the
world Rapids championship it's a
beautiful game from Round three Oliver
Sefolosha I'm currently playing for the
for the feed a flag whatever that means
like we mentioned in the video we've
covered where he faced Carson in the
banter blade session he faces Anton
horrible if you've been covering not
covering if you've been following the
channel for the past few days you know
that Anton Corbijn just won the sanwei
CJIs tournament without a single loss
really he just went into beast mode and
obliterated everyone and even though
horrible may not be be well not yet be
considered and a top elite player when
it comes to classical just in rapid
chess he's actually almost 2800 for a
twenty seven ninety something so
definitely a strong strong opponent for
for younger leaders so let's see what
happens over the board ali reza opens
with efore we have see five quarter both
will go for his night off
as we've seen during the coverage of the
summary sieges tournament Knight f3 d6
we have d4 seek at first Knight captures
Knight f6 Knight to c3 and of course a
6-quart above goes for the for the night
off
variation and as you can see Anton
Horvath there with his fancy profile
photo by Leonard Otis with Bishop to g5
just developing continued development
Knight 9b d7 with Bishop to c4 and Queen
to a5 now putting pressure on the bishop
here earlier as a defensive Queen to d2
and now h6 pushing the bishop back here
Alireza trades decides to give up the
bishop pair we have Bishop California
captures and a queenside castle so white
pretty much finished the development he
wants to play King to be one get the
rook into the game and all the pieces
are perfectly placed Bishop to b3 will
also be a nice nice touch so e six by
black and Bishop to b3 now the bishop is
just much safer there as well you're
expecting this rook to come to c8 and
well just the ATO and c2 pawn are
defended is just a much better square
for the Bishop Bishop to e7 and now King
to be one that always useful Square and
also prevents casting immediately
because of this Knight to d5 trick
you're attacking the bishop and you
don't you have to bring the Queen back
and then white is just able to eliminate
blacks bishop pair as well leaving him
with a much better position because if
you create Queens here then you get
Knight captures on e7 check grabbing a
piece and after the King moves just rook
capture Sundy to be that being the trick
so disrupted b7 he's going to have to
wait with castling a bit with f4 by
Oliveira and the now rook the c8 we have
rook ht1 and rook the c5 so this
position has been reached before but the
move Agha Reza plays Quinta e 2 is a new
move and it is already as a move 15 that
we have a completely new game so there
is nothing better than surprising
Antoine Horeb of when he goes for his
night off
with a move that he made he maybe maybe
he saw it before but I don't think so
because he didn't reply with with the
best reply here
kora both castles and you should really
go Queen to c7 because of the variation
that follows quarter both castled and we
have E 5 here and quarter Bob is not
afraid of e5 but D captures an e5 f
captures on e5 the pawn is protected
twice and Knight back to h7 but now
Knight to f5 and this is the point now
you open up a discovery towards the
bishop on d7 that's why Queen to c7
before castling was perhaps perhaps
somewhat better so here if you capture
and all our rook captures it's just
terrible
the bishop hangs the the b7 pawn hang
see 6 is coming it's just a a terrible
position for blacks so here after Knight
f5 quarter Bob decides to go back Queen
to d8 now or maybe maybe he knows the
line and he just decided that it's also
possible to play like this or although
it looks very not really Pleasant
you're the bishop is now pinned you
cannot move it the the queen is stuck
guarding both the bishops now and we
have Queen to d3 Alireza just brings
another attacker to the bishop we have
looked the c7 core above defense
although it's a it's not really an
impressive square for the rook it's a
very passive square
looked for preparing to get yet another
attacker to the party
we have Bishop to c5 not allowing Ruby
d4 and now ali reza goes back knights
the g3 with ideas of rook to g4 night h5
and going after Cora box King with Queen
g5 not allowing it but h4 oh it is just
that pushes the Queen back and now Queen
to g6 is the move to play it still keeps
you know it's a great square for the
Queen you keep attacking the knight if
you move the rook you can trade Queens
you prevent the Ruby for you prevent
Knight h5 so the Queen g6 really does
the job nicely but quarter battle goes
back Knight to e7 and this allows
Carozza to really activate his pieces we
have rook to g4 King to h8 making room
for Luke to g8 and not Knights to h5
with g6 and now Knight to f4 already
having the threat of rook captures on g6
because if pony captures the knight
captures comes with check and you pick
up the Queen so rogue g8 adding another
defender here and now Knight to e4 now
adding another attacker in the attack
Knight to f6 is coming so with h5
attacking the rook but now Alireza just
goes for it he plays Knight captures on
h5 so a piece sacrifice will G captures
on h5 and rook captures and g8 with King
captors and g8 and Queen the g3 with
check King to h8 and now to finish off
the the sacrificed Knight f6 and it's
just beautiful
first you might think what's the point
the point is because well obviously
you're threatening mate but the point is
after Knight captures and pawn captures
the Queen is under attack but also
you're threatening mate and also you're
threatening to win the rook so there's
really no good move here after Queen
captures you just pick up the rook
you're up the exchange of course in a
completely winning position so here
after Knight to f6 quarter both played
Queen back to f8 he left the defense of
the bishop on d8 even though it's
possible to defend it with Queen to d8
but it just looks so ugly because well
you're the bishop cannot move
you will not be able to really move if
the Queen ever moves here you can still
deliver mate but point is after night
after Queen to d8 you go Queen to f3
the idea is Queen h5 followed by Queen
to h7 mate so Knight captures pawn
captures and now queen of course the
thread is just Queen captures in h5
there's no stopping that
however after Queen to g8 now you can
move and after Queen captures on h5
Queen to h7 and now after Queen back to
e5 you're threatening to win back
material you're attacking the rook if
the rook moves you're winning back your
piece so Bishop to b6 and now Queen to
d6 further attacking the bishop Bishop
to a5 and here we reach this very
exciting position where core above would
keep his extra piece but he is basically
without a move so you can't really do
anything you can't move the rook because
the bishop falls you can't move this
Bishop anywhere useful and it's pretty
much stuck regarding this rook you
cannot move the bishop because you allow
check after the Queen blocks you deliver
check here and then a rook the DA to
deliver you know finishes the job
so here black wouldn't really have any
moves it so but it's a really difficult
position even even to play it it's it's
a disgusting position especially for a
rapid game so quarter bug goes Queen to
f8 and now our eyes adjust wins back the
piece Knight captures on d7 we have
Queen to g7 offering a queen trade but
now Queen f3 not not allowing the trade
also you want to pick of the h5 points
so Queen to g4 defending and also if you
put the Queen to a 2-wheeled square you
might also just get checkmated so Queen
f1 and now Bishop the F do kind of
locking the Queen out of the game
because if captures then again you get
made it but just c3 now the bishop
defends the rook and also the bishop who
now again be a part of this game when it
comes to c2 and starts attacking the
Kings side Queen captures on h4 but now
Bishop the c2 by ali reza we have Knight
to g5 getting the knight in the game but
now Knight to f6 so what's what's the
idea well you want to get the Queen into
the game and
pick off the the h5 point so you can
create some threats using the rook along
the H file so easier said than done but
Alireza goes about it properly also now
you do have some threats along the back
rank so first rook the c8 and now
Queenie do you are now gonna grab the h5
point Bishop back to c5 you don't want
it you don't want it to be a target here
as you do want to activate your queen
Knight captures on h5 we have Russia
back to East 7 taking care of the f6
square but now g3 pushes the Queen
further back Queen h3 and now Knight to
f4 so really making every move count you
want to get the Queen away from there
you want to play queen g2 and you want
to get hook to h1 in so Queen to h6 and
now Queen to g2 and here core above of
course you don't want to lose your queen
after Luke - h1 coral both played Queen
to g7 and now I would ask you to pause
the video but I know you all of you know
what's going to be played so here if you
found the rook to h1 congratulations it
is enough to win the game but ali reza
just played Wow Queen captures Sun b7
and it was in this position I move 42
that Anton core above resigned the game
really really impressive stuff by young
girl it is a taking down well basically
a 2800 player or above is I think is 5th
or 6th you know regarding ranking in
rapid chess in the world so it's just
amazing stuff here you resign because
well the rook is threatened the bishop
is threatened a rook to h1 is coming and
there's just not much you can do here
you can block with the Queen Queen f8
but then rook the h1 check comes and
after you block or you move the King
let's say kimi GA 8 now Queen captures
on a6 or just you know yeah you you can
continue playing this game but there's
not all that much that can be done so
not only that you are up two points and
well it's it's just a completely winning
position for white and of course Corbin
knows this they were both fairly low on
time but
our eyes are being a long time that
that's not really you know something
special because he probably plays bullet
games in the in between the you know
world rabbit championship games so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
you know I would like to thank a dog
McNab Edward Baker
maxime peace an ash tree and 1998 and
torrents fight for a contribution to my
channel I thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
world rabbit championship we still have
to check up on some of the games from
round five and then I'm gonna go through
all of your suggestions hashtag
suggestions of course and check what
other games we've missed as there are
too many of them to be shown either
today or maybe tomorrow morning before
around to starts so once again I think
you're I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day